en este vídeo quiero presentar un nuevo
concepto que es el de línea de
presupuesto le voy a poner aquí línea
línea de presupuesto presupuesto a lo
mejor no es tan nuevo para ti porque hay
algunos ejemplos de álgebra en los
cuales se hace esto que tienes una
cierta cantidad que puedes gastar en
algunos bienes o servicios
pero bueno empezaremos desde cero vamos
a ponerle que es igual al ingreso que
tienes digamos mensualmente y vamos a
suponer que ahorita todo lo que reciben
los gastas entonces es ingreso también
es igual al gasto ahorita voy a trabajar
con variables y por ejemplo aquí voy a
poner y aquí voy a poner otras lo cual
es un poco abstracto pero nos ayuda a
obtener resultados un poco más generales
después vamos a sustituir algunos
números y con eso ya vamos a fijar un
poco más las ideas bueno además de esto
vamos a suponer que esta economía es muy
sencilla que únicamente hay dos bienes
claro en la economía usualmente hay
muchos más bienes y servicios pero
ahorita nada más vamos a suponer que son
dos porque de este modo vamos a poder
graficar todas nuestras posibilidades de
compra aquí en el plano en la pantalla
que es plana
más bienes y servicios tendríamos que
graficar en el espacio o incluso en
lugares más abstractos con lo cual no
nos queremos meter ahorita entonces para
seguir con la continuidad de los bienes
de los vídeos pasados vamos a suponer
que aquí hay chocolates y fruta entonces
otra vez todo lo que compras son
chocolates o fruta de esta forma lo que
gastas es la cantidad de chocolate que
compras por el precio de chocolate más
la cantidad de fruta que compras
la cantidad de fruta que compras por el
precio de la fruta ok entonces lo que
nos gustaría hacer es graficar la
cantidad de chocolate contra la cantidad
de fruta de alguna forma entonces para
esto déjame poner unos ejes por acá y
ahorita empezamos a pensar en cosas un
poco más concretas y aquí voy a poner el
eje de la cantidad de chocolate de este
lado voy a poner el eje de la cantidad
de fruta le voy a escribir por ahí le
voy a escribir por ahí la cantidad de
fruta y del otro lado tenemos la
cantidad de chocolate sale y para fijar
más o menos las ideas ahorita vamos a
pensar que nuestro ingreso es de 200
pesos mensuales para que cada chocolate
que cada chocolate que el precio por
chocolate es de 10 pesos por barra 10 10
pesos por barra
y que el precio de la fruta que el
precio de la fruta es de 20 pesos por
kilo entonces es 20 pesos por kilo
ok entonces mira si esto ya son números
y éstas ya son constantes podríamos
ponerlas aquí sea igual a 200 pc igual a
10 pf igual a 20 y entonces ya
tendríamos la ecuación de una recta
entonces lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
despejar la cantidad de chocolate en
términos de la cantidad de fruta pero
sin meter estos números es decir de
manera general para que podamos ir
agarrando algunas interpretaciones y
cosas por el estilo ya después hasta el
final vamos a ponerle los números
y entonces primero voy a poner esta esta
igualdad e igual a esta cosa de acá sin
poner esto intermedio le voy a poner que
es igual a la cantidad de chocolate por
el precio del chocolate más la cantidad
de fruta por el precio de la fruta de
fruta por el precio de la fruta y
insisto quiero despejar la cantidad de
chocolate entonces lo primero que voy a
hacer es restar la cantidad de fruta por
el precio de la fruta de ambos lados de
este lado y de este lado para que la
igualdad se preserven y entonces que
obtenemos obtenemos que y menos la
cantidad de fruta por el precio de la
fruta por el precio de la fruta de este
lado se cancela esto se cancela nos
queda igual
la cantidad de chocolate por el precio
del chocolate cantidad de chocolate por
precio de chocolate ahora voy a dividir
entre el precio del chocolate entonces
voy a dividir de este lado entre el
precio del chocolate y de este lado
también entre el precio del chocolate
entonces al lado izquierdo nada más nos
va a quedar la cantidad de chocolate
bueno al lado al lado derecho pero lo
voy a pasar para el lado izquierdo y nos
va a quedar que eso es igual allí entre
el precio de chocolate y ahorita lo
pongo entre el precio de chocolate menos
el precio de la fruta entre el precio de
chocolate precio de la fruta entre el
precio del chocolate por la cantidad de
fruta ahora si me voy al color del
chocolate aquí es precio de chocolate y
aquí también es precio del chocolate
ahora no no quiero quedarme en términos
muy abstractos llegó ahorita ya podemos
aquí ya quedó despejado la cantidad de
chocolate pero ahora sí ya podemos
sustituir entonces vamos a ir
sustituyendo y pensando qué quieren
decir las cosas para se cuente esta
división de acá pues está muy sencilla
de hacer verdad está
ya que tenemos ciertos numeritos
simplemente es 200 entre el precio del
chocolate que nos quedaría 20 entonces
eso eso está sencillo lo voy a poner por
aquí que es igual a 20 va pero lo
importante es que entendamos qué quiere
decir este término de acá luego en el
álgebra se van escondiendo ciertos
significados padres que no nos pues no
nos detenemos a ver entonces esto es
dividir lo que ganamos entre el precio
del chocolate yo digo que estoy acá lo
podemos pensar como un ingreso ingreso
real
real a qué me refiero con ingreso real
pues usualmente el dinero es un concepto
abstracto que va cambiando su valor con
el paso del tiempo por ejemplo no tiene
el mismo poder adquisitivo 200 pesos en
1913 que en 2013 va entonces como va
cambiando tienes que compararlo con que
puedes comprar y que no para saber
realmente cuánto ganas que realmente
cuánto puedes obtener en bienes y
servicios entonces justo hacer esta
división hace eso si dividimos lo que
tenemos entre el precio nos dice cuánto
podemos comprar cuántas barras podemos
comprar entonces este 20 es una forma de
pensar nuestro ingreso en términos de
barras de chocolate es algo un poco más
apegado a la realidad de modo similar
pudimos haber hecho hoy entre pf y
obtener nuestro ingreso en kilos de
fruta que nos quedaría 200 entre 20 y 10
kilos de fruta
entonces este término es una forma de
traer lo que ganamos algo un poco más
concreto
vamos con el segundo ahora tenemos pf
entre pc entonces acá tenemos pf el
precio de la fruta que es igual a 20
pesos por kilo le voy a poner así mira
20 pesos psd pesos por kilo y eso lo
vamos a dividir lo vamos a dividir entre
el precio del chocolate que es de 10
pesos por barra barra
una vez más la división de 20 entre 10
es muy sencilla a 23 días simplemente 2
y 12
es 12 así facilitó ok pero en qué
unidades nos queda aquí tenemos que
hacer ley del sándwich verdad nos queda
aquí hay una fracción y aquí hay otra
fracción aquí en el denominador del
numerador tenemos kilos en el
denominador del denominador tenemos bar
entonces hay que hacer este por este y
éste por este pero los precios los baja
el pp de pesos perdón se va a cancelar
la barra va a quedar arriba entonces
este 2 este 2 déjame borrarlo y ponerlo
el 2 lo voy a poner así con color azul
pero lo que nos va a quedar en unidades
es barra barra
y abajo kilo
entonces nos queda barras entre kilos
qué quiere decir esto esto lo que quiere
decir es cada kilo de fruta cuántas
barras de chocolate me da otra forma de
pensarlo es como un costo de oportunidad
esto de aquí es un costo de oportunidad
costo de oportunidad oportunidad o sea
por cada kilo adicional de fruta que yo
quiera cuántas barras de chocolate tengo
que sacrificar cuántas barras de
chocolate tengo que regresar o qué que
dejar que va a dejar de comprar bueno
entonces ya tenemos una bonita
interpretación para este para barra
entre kilo y anna más vamos a poner este
2 digo finalmente para graficar sólo nos
importa que sea un 2
y acá nos queda la cantidad de fruta la
cantidad de fruta entonces que obtenemos
obtenemos que la cantidad de chocolate
es igual a 20 menos 2 veces la cantidad
de fruta ahora sí podemos graficar esto
aquí como si fuera una recta verdad ya
está en la forma igual a mx más b bueno
con un poco de reacomodo pero ya viendo
esto de acá como podemos graficar lápiz
podemos ir poniendo algunos puntos para
q df verdad por ejemplo qué pasa si
ponemos q df igual a 0 si no compramos
nada de fruta si no compramos nada de
fruta entonces podemos comprar 20 barras
de chocolate 20 barras lo voy a poner
aquí es 20 que por acá es 10 vale
entonces aquí sería 5 15 ok entonces
este punto de acá déjame ponerlo con
otro color este punto verde está en las
posibilidades que podemos comprar lo
cual tiene sentido verdad si no
compramos nada de fruta estos 200 pesos
los podemos gastar en 20 barras de
chocolate ahora cómo le hacemos para
encontrar otro punto pues podríamos
pensar que ahora no compramos nada de
chocolate y despejar de aquí la cantidad
de fruta que podemos comprar pero
también podemos verlo desde acá arriba o
sea si tenemos 200 pesos y todo lo
gastamos en fruta cuánto podemos comprar
pues 20 kilos de fruta verdad entonces
si no compramos nada de chocolate
podemos comprar a no no no podemos
comprar 20 podemos comprar 10 kilos de
fruta
supongamos que aquí son 10 kilos de
fruta y que por acá son 5 ok entonces
esta es otra posibilidad otra
posibilidad es no comprar chocolate pero
comprar 10 kilos de fruta bueno ya
teniendo estos dos puntos y sabiendo que
estoy aquí es una recta podemos trazar
esta recta de acá
en la cual déjame utilizar la
herramienta de línea para que quede
derechito esta recta de acá en la cual
están todas nuestras posibilidades de
compra pero ojo son todas las
posibilidades de comprar siempre y
cuando tanto el chocolate como la fruta
se puedan vender en las fracciones tan
pequeñas como querramos en fracciones
muy chiquitas por ejemplo un tercio de
chocolate o un octavo de chocolate bueno
esa es una condición o también puedes
pensar esto a largo plazo por ejemplo si
compras seis chocolates cada 12 meses
entonces puedes pensar que estás
comprando medio chocolate al mes bueno
la cosa es que hay que tener un poquito
de cuidado para que esto ya de veras sea
una línea pero una vez que esto es una
línea se le conoce como línea de
presupuesto
línea de presupuesto presupuesto y de
aquí se pueden leer varias cosas
interesantes por ejemplo su pendiente
cual es la pendiente es esto que es
menos 2 aquí son barras por kilo verdad
que son 2 y aquí es menos 2 esto de acá
entonces que quiere decir que la
pendiente de esta recta sea menos 2 pues
justo quiere decir que si avanzamos un
kilo de fruta déjame ponerle por acá
vamos a ponerle que este de aquí es un
avance de un kilo de fruta entonces
cuanto estamos sacrificando en
chocolates y justo estamos sacrificando
dos chocolates por cada kilo de fruta
adicional que compramos hay dos
chocolates que ya no podemos comprar
bueno entonces esta también era otra
forma de graficar verdad poníamos un
punto nos fijamos en la pendiente y con
eso nos quedaba la recta pero bueno eso
de ahí es es la línea de presupuesto y
además de la línea de presupuesto hay
dos regiones que nos interesan una es la
región de acá adentro
y otras la región de acá afuera pero qué
sucede con un punto acá pues ve un punto
acá si puedes comprar esta cantidad de
fruta y de chocolate con lo que tienes
porque de hecho puedes comprar incluso
más verdad si te vas para arriba y
agarras más chocolates puedes comprar
más entonces de esta región se llama la
región de lo asequible asequible que
justamente es pues lo que sí para lo que
si te alcanza así de modo similar lo que
está aquí afuera es la región de lo
inaccesible
inasequible porque veo sea justo comprar
esta cantidad de fruta de chocolate es
esa actitud con lo que ganas ya coincide
con lo que ganas pero si quieres comprar
todavía más fruta pues no no te vas o
más chocolate no te va a alcanzar
entonces está la línea de presupuesto
arriba está lo inasequible abajo está lo
asequible y ya nada más como comentario
final se parece mucho a los de la de la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
porque ahí también teníamos una curva
que era la curva de producción eficiente
arriba de la curva de producción
eficiente estaba lo que no podíamos
producir lo inalcanzable y abajo de la
curva de producción estaba lo alcanzable
pero
ineficiente